l'ordre voici en voilà le président
emmanuel macron qui vient de signer le
procès verbal de son investiture comme
grand maître de l'ordre
il prend place au pupitre pour son
premier discours en tant que président
et le président du conseil
constitutionnel
mesdames et messieurs les présidents
mesdames messieurs les français ont
choisi vous l'avez rappelé le 7 mai
dernier
l'espoir est l'esprit de conquête le
monde entier à regarder notre élection
présidentielle partout se demander si
les français allaient décidé à leur tour
de se replier sur le passé illusoire
s'il allait rompre avec la marche du
monde quittait la scène de l'histoire
céder à la défiance démocratique
l'esprit de division et tourner le dos
aux lumières ou si au contraire il
allait embrasser l'avenir se donner
collectivement un nouvel élan réaffirmé
leur foi dans les valeurs qui ont fait
d'eux un grand peuple
le 7 mai les français ont choisi qu'il
en soit ici remercié la responsabilité
qu'ils m'ont confié est un honneur dont
je mesure la gravité le monde et
l'europe ont aujourd'hui plus que jamais
besoin de la france
ils ont besoin d'une france forte et sûr
de son destin
ils ont besoin d'une france qui porte
haut la voix de la liberté et de la
solidarité
ils ont besoin d'une france qui sache
inventer l'avenir
le monde a besoin de ce que les
françaises et les français lui ont
toujours enseigné l'audace de la liberté
l'exigence de l'égalité
la volonté de la fraternité
or depuis des décennies la france doute
d'elle même elle se sent menacée dans sa
culture dans son modèle social dans ses
croyances profondes
elle doute de ce qu'il a fait voilà
pourquoi mon mandat sera guidée par deux
exigences la première sera de rendre aux
français
cette confiance en eux depuis trop
longtemps affaibli
oh je vous rassure je n'ai pas pensé une
seule seconde qu'elle se resterait comme
par magie le soir du 7 mai ce sera un
travail lent exigeant mais indispensable
il m'appartiendra de convaincre les
françaises et les français que notre
pays qui aujourd'hui semble mise à mal
par les vents parfois contraire du cours
du monde porte en son sein toutes les
ressources pour figurer au premier rang
des nations
je convaincrai nos compatriotes que la
puissance de la france n'est pas
déclinantes que nous sommes à l'orée
d'une extraordinaire renaissance parce
que nous tenons entre nos mains tous les
atouts qui feront et qui font les
grandes puissances du 21e siècle
pour cela je ne céderai sur rien des
engagements pris vis-à-vis des français
tous ceux qui concourent à la vie dure
de la france et à sa prospérité sera
mise en oeuvre
le travail sera libéré les entreprises
seront soutenus
l'initiative sera encouragé la culture
et l'éducation par lesquels se construit
l'émancipation la création et
l'innovation seront au coeur de mon
action les françaises et les français
qui se sentent oubliés par ce vaste
mouvement du monde vont se voir mieux
protéger tout ce qui forge notre
solidarité nationale sera refonder
réinventer fortifiée l'égalité face aux
accidents de la vie sera renforcée
tout ce qui fait de la france un pays
sûr où l'on peut vivre sans avoir peur
sera amplifié la laïcité républicaine
sera défendu nos forces de l'ordre notre
renseignement nos armes et réconfortés
l'europe dont nous avons besoin sera
refonder relancer car elle nous protège
et nous permet de porter dans le monde
nos valeurs nos institutions
décrié par certains doivent retrouver
aux yeux des français l'efficacité qui
en a garanti la pérennité car je crois
aux institutions de la vème république
et ferait tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
pour qu'elle fonctionne selon l'esprit
qui les a fait naître pour cela je
veillerai à ce que notre pays connaisse
un regain de vitalité démocratique
les citoyens auront voix au chapitre ils
seront écoutés dans ce combat j'aurai
besoin de chacun la responsabilité de
toutes les élites politiques économiques
sociales religieuses de tous les corps
constitués de la nation française sera
appelée nous pouvons plus nous réfugier
derrière des usages ou des habitudes
parfois hors du temps nous devons
retrouver le sens profond
la dignité de ceux qui aujourd'hui nous
rassemble agir de manière juste et
efficace pour notre peuple
la france mais forte que si elle est
prospère
la france n'est un modèle pour le monde
que si elle est exemplaire et c'est là
ma seconde exigence parce que nous
aurons rendu aux français le goût de
l'avenir et la fierté de ce qu'ils sont
le monde entier sera attentif à la
parole de la france parce que nous
aurons su dépasser ensemble nos craintes
de nos angoisses nous donneront ensemble
l'exemple d'un peuple ça chante infirmer
ses valeurs et ses principes qui sont
ceux de la démocratie et de la
république
les efforts de mes prédécesseurs en ce
sens ont été remarquables et je veux ici
les saluer je songe au général de gaulle
qui devra pour redresser la france et
lui rendre son rang dans le concert des
nations
je songe à georges pompidou qui fit de
notre pays une puissance industrielle
majeure à valéry giscard d'estaing qui
sut faire entrer la france et sa société
dans la modernité à françois mitterrand
qui accompagna la réconciliation du rêve
français et du rêve européen à jacques
chirac
nous donnons le rang d'une nation
sachant dire non aux prétentions des
va-t-en guerre à nicolas sarkozy ne
comptant pas son énergie pour résoudre
la crise financière qui avait si
violemment frappé le monde et je songe
bien sûr à françois hollande faisant
oeuvre de précurseur avec l'accord de
paris sur le climat et protégeant les
français dans un monde frappés par le
terrorisme
leurs oeuvres surtout ces dernières
décennies
c'est trop souvent vu empêcher par un
climat intérieur délétère par le
découragement de françaises et de
français s'estimant injustement
défavorisés des classes et oublier ce
que la france avait à dire au monde
c'est parfois trouvé affaibli par une
situation nationale percluses
d'inquiétude voire de défiance
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs le
temps est venu pour la france de se
hisser à la hauteur du moment
la division et les fractures qui
parcourent notre société doivent être
surmontés qu'elle soit économique social
politique ou morale car le monde attend
de nous que nous soyons forts solide et
clairvoyant
la mission de la france dans le monde
est imminente
nous prendrons toutes nos
responsabilités pour apporter chaque
fois que cela sera nécessaire une
réponse pertinente aux grandes crises
contemporaines qu'il s'agisse de la
crise migratoire du défi climatique des
dérives autoritaires des excès du
capitalisme mondial et bien sûr du
terrorisme
plus rien désormais ne frappe les uns en
épargnant les autres nous sommes tous
interdépendants
nous sommes tous voisins la france
veillera toujours à être aux côtés de la
liberté des droits de l'homme mais
toujours pour construire la paix dans la
durée nous avons un rôle immense
corriger les excès du cours du monde et
veiller à la défense de la liberté
c'est là notre vocation pour ce faire
nous aurons besoin d'une europe plus
efficace plus démocratique plus
politique car elle est l'instrument de
notre puissance et de notre souveraineté
j oeuvre et la géographie s'est
singulièrement rétréci mais le temps
s'est accéléré nous vivons une période
qui décidera du destin de la france pour
les décennies qui viennent nous nous
battrons pas seulement pour cette
génération mais pour les générations à
venir
c'est à nous tous
qu'il appartient ici et maintenant de
décider du monde dans lequel ces
générations vivre tel est peut-être
notre plus grande responsabilité
nous avons à construire le monde que
notre jeunesse mérite
je sais que les françaises et les
français en cette heure attendent
beaucoup de moi
ils ont raison car le mandat qu ils me
confient leur donne sur moi le droit
d'une exigence absolue
j'en suis pleinement conscient rien ne
sera concédé à la facilité ni au
compromis rien à faiblir à ma
détermination
rien ne me fera renoncer à défendre en
tout temps et en tout lieu les intérêts
supérieurs de la france j'aurai dans le
même temps la volonté constante de
réconcilier et rassembler l'ensemble des
français la confiance que les françaises
et les français m'ont témoigné mme empli
d'une immense énergie la certitude
intime que nous pouvons ensemble écrire
une des plus belles pages de notre
histoire portera mon action dans ces
instants où tout peut basculer le peuple
français a toujours su trouver l'énergie
le discernement l'esprit de concorde
pour construire le changement profond
nous en sommes là c'est pour cette
mission
cab le mans je servirai notre peuple je
sais pouvoir compter sur tous nos
compatriotes
pour mener à bien la tâche considérable
et exaltante qui nous attend en ce qui
me concerne dès ce soir je serai au
travail
vive la république vive la france
voilà
du discours d' emmanuel macron dès ce
soir je serai au travail bien montrer
qu'il est conscient des enjeux la
présence selon le protocole il va saluer
les personnes qui sont dans la salle des
fêtes son épouse brigitte macron bernard
cazeneuve poignée de mains appuyées
chalet le président du sénat très
chaleureux très chaleureux une deux
hommes se sont rencontrés hier
d'ailleurs l orient d'entretien au sénat
gérard larcher emmanuel mâcon puis
claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée nationale demande général
d'armée à venoix puga lionel josse par
l'ancien premier ministre on va
s'arrêter un petit peu sur ces images
pour justement d'écrire que nous voyons
voit laurent fabius a créé à côté il a
proclamé
c'est lui qui a proclamé les résultats
de l'élection présidentielle parlant
d'une campagne chamboule tout on l'a
souligné avant l investiture d emmanuel
macron les deux amants qui se saluent
chaleureusement aussi en sont heureux
c'est un mot qu'on puisse embrasser peu
conventionnelle de la part du président
du conseil constitutionnel discours plus
politique institutionnelle j'ai trouvé
mais en même temps on sentait la moindre
de la part de laurent fabius
beaucoup d'émotion ce qui n'est pas non
plus chez lui très fréquent et puis
également à lapsus intéressant de 2016 à
la place de 2010 est de mon roi quand on
n'est pas face à un président de la
république très innovant il est
difficile et l'avenir on voit l'image
d'un emmanuel macron qui salue les gens
présents dans la salle des fêtes
également les canons 21 coups de canon
vont être tirés place des poubelles
[Musique]